a former special forces interpreter who
has given his all for the freedom and
defense and interest of our nation is an
urgent need of help himself as kirsten
joyce reports he's trying to rescue his
wife out of afghanistan
h.k as we'll call him to protect his
identity is a u.s citizen from
afghanistan now living in las vegas
watching the images out of afghanistan
in disbelief right now the city is
overwhelmed everybody's scared h.k
served as a combat interpreter for the
united states army in afghanistan for
almost a decade he speaks five languages
i learn all these languages just to be
able to
save the lives of those who came to save
and rescue me and now he desperately
needs help he's been working as an uber
driver on the las vegas strip because it
offers him the flexibility to focus on
his current mission to bring his wife
over from afghanistan the time is
running out
and i'm doing everything i can to get
her out of there well we still have used
troops on the ground we've been close
three times to having her on a plane we
submitted two thousand dollars to him
to get a medical visa to india that was
authorized and pulled back bryant
johnson is the founder of life pulse
determined to share hk's story and find
a way to help right now the images of
people falling off planes as we leave
afghanistan should be considered a
horror show because these are people
that have stuck with us and allowed our
service men and women
to come home safely and every time my
wife asks me
if we were if we are ever gonna see
again and if the fact that she will even
make it
this is harder than being in these
special forces and going out there and
chasing bad guys and defending this
country this is harder for me so on this
day i need any assistance that i can get
from anyone he has spent over a year
working with the department of state and
immigration but approval is backed up in
red tape if the terrorists that we were
fighting for 20 years
if they find out that she's my wife
just imagine what's going to happen to
her
and this life will be meaningless for me
after that kirsten joyce 8 news now